un golpe los cimientos del sistema
electoral en georgia tras la luz verde
del congreso local el gobernador
republicano firmó y convirtió en ley un
polémico proyecto que modifica
radicalmente las leyes electorales en el
estado which will begin working
comenzamos a trabajar con la cámara y el
senado en nuevas reformas para facilitar
la votación y dificultar las trampas
el proyecto que promulga para
convertirlo en ley acceso a la
controversial ley impone diversas
restricciones a la votación por correo
como la obligatoriedad de presentar una
identificación con foto reducir el
tiempo para solicitar las boletas para
el voto en ausencia y limitar la
ubicación de las urnas y su tiempo de
acceso a ellas
la normativa reducirá además el poder de
la junta electoral y la del secretario
de estado brad trofense berger quien
rechazó los intentos de trump por
revertir los resultados de noviembre
dará más poder a la legislatura
actualmente de manos republicanas otra
de las polémicas medidas es la
prohibición de suministrar alimentos y
bebidas en las largas filas de votación
y se es enfermizo
y decidir en algunos estados que no se
puede llevar agua a las personas que
hacen fila esperando para votar y que no
habrá votaciones por correo en las
circunstancias más difíciles la
oposición demócrata denuncia que la ley
busca restringir el acceso al voto por
correo de la población afroamericana en
las últimas elecciones 1,3 millones de
votantes en el estado recurrieron a esta
modalidad de votación algo que fue clave
para convertir a georgia histórico
bastión republicano en uno de los
estados bisagra que llevó a bardem a la
presidencia también en el territorio que
neutralizó el poder conservador en el
senado los republicanos han impulsado
una serie de reformas a las leyes
electorales en varios estados como
arizona michigan o florida bajo
infundado señalamientos de fraude
impulsados por el propio donald trump
tras su derrota
[Música]